key côté terrain michel platini a
dévoilé le logo de la coupe du monde de
football 98 qui aura lieu vous le savez
en france
le ballon est un soleil une façon de
dire que le football est universel
françois brabant et et didier da en 1998
les français ont eu peur de s'ennuyer
alors récent créé à l'image du soleil et
ils sont imaginé un jeu pour le coup
en 1998 les rangs français vos solaire
argument le film holly
france 98
c'est donc le soleil français qui sera
chargée d' illuminé le monde du football
à l'aube du troisième millénaire mais
pour que ce soleil la bri vraiment de
mille feux il faut live good à des jeux
vous voyez venir
oui monsieur rené schmitt qui parlait
pour le renom du rhône au milieu du
ministre des sports nous a dit que la
décision serait imminente et que le vent
sera choisi dans les jours qui viennent
je pense mais la construction du grand
stade n'est pas encore commencée que les
français ont déjà un autre défi à
relever la fifa représenter ce matin par
sepp blatter est revenu très satisfaite
de sa world cup américaine
il va falloir faire aussi bien au moins
je pense qu'on pourra faire beaucoup
mieux
tu plaisantes mais disons pourra pas
faire aussi bien que dans le remplissage
des stades parce que nous avons pas d
stade de 80000 eux ils en ont 70 aux
etats unis des stades de 80 parce qu'on
n'a pas encore envoyé dans ces
difficiles après d'autre part la coupe
du monde aux états unis ça a été une
coupe du monde
coca cola nous ce sera une coupe du
monde champagne
bon résumons on a le logo on a l'esprit
on va bientôt avoir le stade
on va aussi connaître les villes reste à
trouver le joueur qui la brandir à cette
coupe en 98